petit coup de cuillère nous étions ici
sur ce plateau et nous avons parlé des
gilet jaune pour voilà et il y avait qu
à ina qui étaient avec nous qui faisait
partie du mouvement et qui voulait faire
entendre sa voix comme tous les
manifestants gilet jaune sur cette
émission
rappelez vous c'était hier soir regarde
ni leoni qui les jaunes en région par
les efficaces alors peser ballet onysos
et kahina moi je suis étudiante
actuellement je paye des gaulois ont
quoi quand même dans une école de
commerce
alors je suis en mal d'ailleurs en
alternance donc je touche 900 euros 900
euros je dois payer un loyer 900 euros
je dois me magnée 900 euros et wap et
mes transports 200 euros je tape
électricité 900 euros je dois payer la
taxe d'habitation que jeune recevoir
alors je fais comment maintenant alors
kahina alors vous êtes mon coup de
gueule de jours c'est pas vous mon coup
de gueule mais vous êtes mon coup de
gueule parce que depuis hier soir sur
twitter c'est la folie les gens crient
au complot
apparemment on se connaissait regarder
on va voir une revue de tweets je
voudrais tout nous expliquer à tous les
téléspectateurs
parce que c'est incroyable regardé comme
le montrent ces photos ce n'est pas la
première fois que cette fausse gilet
jaune apparaît dans une émission de
cyril hanouna
la première fois c'était en 2013 et
comme par hasard elle était là pour
rabaisser le manger les jaunes ont tous
mythomane de ses huit donc lui monsieur
bleu blanc rouge un abruti fini on va
voir les photos tpm pk inaf au gilet
jaune avait déjà gagné son match donc il
met une photo de la personne qui n'a
rien à voir avec l'autre personne donc
le mec il est sûr de lui serrer une
photo voilà donc il est sûr de lui donc
voilà à la diète au sud on doit elle
avait gagné le concours a déclaré karina
24 ans infirmière habitants à venir
c'est vous ça allait pas marrer
l'oreille vous n'avez pas gagné là bas
on voit bien que la dame elle va avec
son mari déjà je suis pas mariée j'ai 23
ans la fille elle a 24 ans auquel un an
de plus que moi il ya cinq ans affirme
hier je suis en école de commerce
j'aime pas le sens non mais c'est un
combat vital alors il n'y a plus que ça
voilà l'incroyable manipulation
d'animaux avec son ami kahina alors qui
des tweets comme ça alors on va boire
vous fait une revue de tweets alesi ya
de scandaleux alors là et aussi c'est
bien la même personne avec cette caméra
cachée ça n'a rien à voir pas du tout la
même personne mais les personnes tous et
ils sont persuadés doit il
mais en plus on voit bien qu'il est
beaucoup plus gros non mais alors moi je
vous dirai ça ça la limite qui est des
gens qui twitte voilà non mais j'ai des
gens qui twitte mais deux que derrière
il y ait des journalistes oui qui
reprennent derrière franchement faites
votre travail les mecs parce que
derrière qu'est ce qu'on a vu on a vu
donc des articles télé loisirs points
comme cette gilet jaune avait-elle déjà
participé à d'autres démissions de cyril
hanouna les téléspectateurs s'interroge
donc ils ont fait tout un article
cette bande mais je vais le dire cette
bande d'abrutis voilà je vous le dis
voilà qui veulent faire que des clics et
faire n'importe quoi je suis désolé j'ai
rien contre eux télé loisirs d'habitude
voilà il est aisé de faire leur travail
mais de plus en plus ils font n'importe
quoi de plus en plus vous allez dire
n'importe quoi ils vont faire derrière
un article arrêter quand ce qu'on
appelle les [ __ ] à cliquer vous êtes
vraiment des vrais [ __ ] à cliquer télé
loisirs c'est n'importe quoi renseignez
vous avant donc ils ont fait tout un
artiste on voit bien que ces trois
personnes une relation différente et il
fait tout un article et derrière ils
disent pas si c'est vous c'est un faux
il laisse le doute matthew weiner
technique justement versé un peu
derrière pour leur dire mais vous faites
n'importe quoi sinon on a juste posé la
question là ouais mais tu essaies donner
la réponse normalement oui pour la
question ce qui fait que derrière ils
s'en sortent comme ça j'ai été interrogé
par l'express par l'express styles ou
applis mais les mecs mais si elle aussi
trouvé que je ressemblais pas du tout
aux photos et elle voulait démentir
cette information alors ça a été démenti
de leur pôle express
ils ont eu leur bac brun aussi qu'il y
avait qu avait mis un tweet et qui avait
dit voilà wissam et puis il a mis j'ai
supprimé mon toute sûreté pmp sont
effectives tête est effectivement pas la
même fille dans la grande race rats et
c'est pour nous c'est cadeau 5 a gagné
le voyage au brésil et qui a représenté
les gilets jaunes
désolé c'est incroyable de faire de
faire des bêtises pareilles et de dire
des conneries pareilles a vraiment télé
loisirs fêtes soyez un petit peu sérieux
on n'a rien contre vous mais on va
commencer à voir quelque chose contre
vous l'outil les limites des réseaux
sociaux c'est cyril reconnaissez au
septembre oui bien sûr même si j'adore
ça et je m'en sert énormément on va
passions et centres d'intérêt
c'est une chose qui soit reprise en a
bien une autre bien sûr nos maisons
les loisirs qui fait un affront je sais
pas ce que vous en pensez chez vous
j'aimerais bien avoir votre avis
là-dessus ce qui est incroyable c'est
que tu s'excuser après ça n'empêche pas
le mal qui a été fait exactement deux le
mal a été beaucoup plus retentissant que
les excuses après v il reste toujours
quelque chose de la cale aux calomnies
qu'à la faiblesse des témoignages parce
que pardon mais les sans être
portraitiste des trois visages non non
pas de point commun c'est ça ne
ressemble à rien il faut pas eu le temps
des joyaux tonnes soit abrutis pour
savoir que ce sont pas les trois mêmes
personnes il avait raison de le dénoncer
parce qu'à chaque fois qu'on peut vous
taper dessus ils le font sans vérifier
donc c'est lamentable
lassé honte à tous alors ceux qui ont
fait ça je vous le dis on essaie d'aider
on essaie de faire avancer les choses
on fait venir des gens ici qui s'exprime
c'est c'est eux qui m'avait demandé la
première fois vous étiez la kahina
dehors voilà si vous pouviez vous
exprimer sur un plateau on a été les
premiers à faire parler énormément de
gilet jaune
voilà et derrière on a des ddd des
abrutis pareil qui nous cassent le
travail et qui disent des inepties
voilà donc franchement arrêtez faites
votre travail soyez un peu sérieux et
arrêter de faire des d'essayer de faire
du buzz sur notre dos voilà si vous
voulez vous savez quoi ne parlait plus
de nous on sera très content voilà je
vous lis
ne parlez pas lieu on n'a pas besoin on
n'a pas besoin de vous franchement on
n'a pas besoin de vous voilà après ça va
s'étonner qu'ils aient des gens qui
s'énervent sur les cas certains articles
sûr qu'il soit énervé contre un certain
certaines plus taklit voilà je vous le
dis donc ça c'est insupportable